>> Tucker: THE MIGRANT CARAVAN
IS FAKE.
YOU'VE BEEN WATCHING CNN SO YOU
KNOW THAT.
LOOK AT THIS GRAPHIC, "INVASION"
AND THEN MYTH.
IT'S A MYTH, A PERNICIOUS ONE.
IS IT ACTUALLY?
AMI HOROWITZ DECIDED TO FIND OUT
HIMSELF.
HE WENT TO MEXICO LOOKING FOR
THE FAKE CARAVAN, FOUND A REAL
CARAVAN AND FILLED IT.
>> DESPITE THE FRAMING OF THE
CARAVAN BEING FULL OF WOMEN AND
CHILDREN, THE REALITY ON THE
GROUND IS QUITE DIFFERENT.
PROXIMALLY 90-95% OF THE
MIGRANTS ARE MALE.
THE MAJOR NARRATIVE BEING PUSHED
BY THE PRESS HAS BEEN THAT THE
MIGRANTS ARE LEAVING HONDURAS
BECAUSE THEY ARE ESCAPING
EXTREME GUIDANCE.
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO ENTER THE
LESSON BY ASKING FOR ASYLUM.
I STARTED BY ASKING THEM A
SIMPLE QUESTIONNAIRE.
>> WHY ARE YOU COMING TO AMERIC
AMERICA?
>> [SPEAKING IN SPANISH]
>> IT'S CLEARLY COSTING SOMEONE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
TRANSPORTATION, FOOD, WATER,
MEDICINE AND SERVICES THAT ARE
BEING PROVIDED BY THE MEMBERS OF
THE CARAVAN.
THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT ALSO
SEEMS TO BE SENDING POLICE TO
ESCORT THE DOZENS OF BUSES AND
TRUCKS THAT ARE CARRYING
MIGRANTS AND SUPPLIES ALONG THE
ROUTE TO THE NEXT GENERATION.
PLAID AND BLACK T-SHIRTS AND
COLORED EVENTS.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT SEEM TO
BE MOST INVOLVED IN ORGANIZING
AND MOBILIZING THIS CARAVAN.
THE ORGANIZATION AS THE NAME
IMPLIES IS LOOKING TO CREATE A
WORLD WITHOUT BORDERS WHICH
SEEMS TO BE THE REASON WHY THEY
ORGANIZE THE CARAVAN AND THE
FIRST PLACE, TO FLOUT AMERICAN
SOVEREIGNTY.
THERE IS AN UNDENIABLE ELEMENT.
>> [SPEAKING IN SPANISH" >> IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT THERE ARE
LEFTIST ORGANIZATIONS USING
THESE MIGRANTS AS A TOOL TO PUSH
A CERTAIN POLITICAL AGENDA WHICH
INCLUDES THE WEAKENING OF
SOVEREIGNTY IN OUR BORDER
SECURITY.
UNFORTUNATELY THESE MIGRANTS ARE
GOING TO BE CAUGHT IN THE
CROSS FIRE.
>> Tucker: AMI HOROWITZ JOINS
US TONIGHT.
THAT WAS REALLY INTERESTING.
THE THING THAT JUMPED OUT AT ME
WAS THAT YOU SAID HOW ORGANIZED
IT WAS.
I KNOW WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
SPECULATE, BUT WHAT DO WE KNOW
THE ANSWER?
>> Ami: WE DO NOT BUT WHAT WE
DO KNOW IS THIS THING COST
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
IN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA, SO MANY
LAYERS OF ONIONS TO PEEL BACK,
IT'S HARD TO KNOW WHERE TO BEGI
BEGIN.
THE MEDIA IS TRYING TO PROPAGATE
THE FACT THAT ALL THIS WEIRD
ORGANIC THING AND ALL THE WATER
AND THE FOOD AND MEDICINE, AT
ALL DROPPED FROM HEAVEN.
IT'S ALL HIGHLY ORGANIZED AND
PAID FOR BY A NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS, AND WE DO KNOW
THAT THE MAIN GROUP WAS
ORGANIZED THIS CARAVAN WITH A
COUPLE OF THE FRONT
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE
UNITED STATES AND THE MONEY IS
FLOWING FROM THEM.
WE KNOW THERE ARE SOME LEFTIST
GROUPS, IT'S FORBIDDEN TO SAY
THAT SOROS IS PART OF IT BUT HE
HAS FUNDED AT LEAST SOME OF
THOSE GROUPS IN THE PAST.
SO WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THE MONEY
IS EXACTLY COMING FROM BUT WE
KNOW IT'S NOT COMING FROM
HONDURAS.
>> Tucker: IT SUCH AN
INTERESTING AND OBVIOUS
QUESTION, WHO IS PAYING FOR
THIS.
WHY HAVEN'T OTHER NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS GOT INTO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS.
YOU ARE ONE MAN DOING THIS
INDEPENDENTLY.
WHY ISN'T NBC OR PBS ON THIS?
>> Ami: YOU KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THAT.
THE SAME REASON WHY, I SEE A
PHOTO IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES" OR
"THE WASHINGTON POST" OR A VIDEO
ON CNN OR THE BBC OR MSNBC.
WHAT DO YOU SEE?
THE ENTIRE FRAMING ARE WOMEN AND
CHILDREN WHEN THE REALITY IS SO
FAR FROM THE TRUTH, 90-95% OF
ALL THE PEOPLE IN THIS CARAVAN
WERE MEN.
ALTHOUGH I DO APOLOGIZE FOR
ASSUMING THEIR GENDER.
BECAUSE THEY ARE LIARS, THAT'S